still to this day get people tagging me
that i know
and say bro are you seeing this i'm like
how are we lads if you haven't seen
these people in the last week on twitter
then you have not been online i'm here
with the four likes behind the picture
gotta ask the question everyone's
wondering what is the story behind the
picture so we're going out and going for
a night out drinking vodka on the train
i think we were
i can't even remember anything we've
come out the train station before we're
gonna just get a picture
we asked a stranger like we had some
random like
take a photo of us the worst thing is we
didn't even get that many pictures at
night
i was going to say i've seen that one
and then i've seen the one on the booth
with the grey goose
i'm so glad i dodged that picture how
old is this picture anywhere almost a
year and a half
one thing everyone was wondering as well
is like are you all right with the memes
yeah we've got to be angry some of the
comments are just ridiculous like if if
you were to actually take it on board
and like
take it to heart what is the point i was
having a lot of skinny jeans on yeah
we smoked well i'm six foot four man
i've got skinny legs better than wearing
blue cuts anyway
what they expect you guys to wear are
they long shorts or short longs
i think that's for you mate that's who
you are three
the fellow who actually made this
picture was me and i tweeted it
yesterday
no before i reveal the answer
to 18 000 votes which one do you reckon
the best looking
rooney rooney all day long i can reveal
the winner
was connor
and i'm gonna have to say for once the
people's voice is right what's not
ironic because that's why you got slated
for the most now it's come up
are the glasses for like do you need
them to see or they're just like
fashionable
oh i thought air fashion but clearly
we're not fashionable
so there was this one as well who's this
imposter i'm not even in that one am i
always there in a way because i got
photoshopped in the window i didn't know
oh
apparently someone actually found a
similar knights held you in the fellas
when i was
oh you know what middle kind of looks
like me when i was a kid as well that's
the last one we've got to send in it's
got to be the c shanty one
oh no i'm leaving this was a ship that
put to see the name of the ship was a
bully of tea
the winds blew up her bird up turned
[Music]
is
it's literally just how lace is singing
and we all just join in together
what would you say is the weirdest dm
you've had so far have you ever come to
dublin come for a beer and some
asking who is the hardest would alex
take us both or all three of us
who reckons the hardest like is the
strongest in this chat all day
he's the gary barlow with a group when's
the world tour then boys
whatever they're ready for anyone asking
when we're coming to australia
when the cove is in that stern we're
gone every single club in the uk is
getting hit up by these fellas
and well and truly deserve it